[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette photo a été prise le 4 août 2020
quelques secondes avant l'explosion du
port de beyrouth vous en avez tous
probablement entendu parler et pour
remettre les choses en perspective cette
explosion a été classée parmi les plus
désastreuses jamais enregistrées avec
plus de 200 morts et 5000 blessés et
plus de 300000 personnes déplacées
laissant des traces remarquable jusqu'à
présent
je m'appelle ryan mahfoud je suis un
étudiant à l'essec en première année du
programme global dédié égide est en 2002
au liban dans un petit village landais
et 18 ans après j'ai décidé de venir en
france à paris en septembre 2020 même
pas un mois après l'explosion du port de
beyrouth et ce soir je vais vous
raconter mon histoire
le 4 août 2020 à 18h07 exactement la vie
de tout mon peuple a changé et la mienne
aussi
en un clin d'oeil plus rien n'était
comme avant
des familles a jamais séparé des enfants
retrouvés orphelins et des dommages
matériels
énormes
chanceux que je suis j'étais bien loin
de l'explosion quand elle a eu lieu mais
son impact émotionnel était tout autant
dur
le 5 août 2020 comme beaucoup de jeunes
libanais je suis parti à la capitale
pour aider les blessés
et c'est au 16e étage d'un immeuble en
ruines que j'ai pris cette photo
autour de moi que des bouts de verre
partout et des meubles cassés en bas
dans la rue des gens qui crient et qui
courent dans tous les sens perdue est
pris par la peur c'est dans ce genre de
situation que certaines personnes
deviennent cicatriser psychologiquement
et physiquement c'est le cas pour tous
les événements tragiques comme les
attentats à new york en 2001 où les
attentats du bataclan en 2015
pour moi ce fut le plus gros déclic de
ma vie ça ce moment même que je
reconsidérerai ma vie et ce soir je
viens partager ça avec vous en espérant
pouvoir vous offrir une nouvelle manière
de voir les choses le 5 août 2020 était
la journée la plus difficile de ma vie
mais les moments difficiles sont
abondants tout le monde a déjà vécu une
expérience assez compliqué et on nous
dit ce qui ne nous tue pas nous rend
plus fort mais comment faire pour
surmonter ces difficultés comment faire
pour se délester de cette angoisse qui
prend le dessus que ce soit par rapport
au passé au présent et même au futur
comment faire pour les surmonter
car vivre des expériences difficiles ne
signifie pas qu'on a qu'on les a
surmontés et qu'on en a appris une leçon
pour la vie le simple fait de vivre ces
expériences est différent du fait de les
surmonter les intériorisée et les
assimiler à notre regard pour la vie et
en apprendre le son on nous dit aussi
chercher ce dont vous avez besoin non
pas ce que vous désirez
et ce soir j'espère pouvoir vous aider à
trouver ce que vous vous avez besoin
excusez moi
mais expérience m'a appris beaucoup de
choses mais j'en retiens une leçon
composé de trois étapes
la première étape s'intitule
reconsidérer qui signifie considérer à
nouveau soit regardé attentivement une
nouvelle fois cette étape paraît assez
simple mais en effet c'est la plus
compliquée car elle nécessite une
caractéristique assez rare de nos jours
être lucide une personne lucide c'est
une personne qui jugent rationnellement
le monde qui les entoure c'est une
personne qui voit les choses dans leur
objectivité et pour moi c'est une
personne qui sait se demander les bonnes
questions pour tous sujets abordés j'ai
commencé à développer cette
caractéristique d un très jeune âge
je me demandais beaucoup de questions
sur des sujets qui étaient assez négligé
par les gens qui avaient le même âge que
moi que ça soit sur la vie la mort la
religion ou même le patriotisme mais je
me suis rendu compte à un certain moment
que mes questions engendrer d'autres
questions et non pas de réponse
du coup j'étais constamment dans un
dans une situation de perte je me sens
je me sentais perdue je n'avais pas des
réponses à mes questions et je remettais
je remettais en considération les
piliers de ma vie les choses que j'avais
pris comme acquis dès le début et cette
sensation est horrible mais je me suis
rendu compte de la valeur de cette
caractéristique un peu plus tard dans ma
vie durant l'année la plus compliquée
pour moi l'année 2020
élève en classe de terminale dans un
lycée sur la côte libanaise je commence
ma dernière année d'adolescents rempli
d'espoir et de rêve
mais je me rend compte assez rapidement
que le destin avait quelque chose
d'autre prévu pour moi
j'écoutais les histoires des plus vieux
qui racontaient leur année et je
m'imaginais avec mes amis en train de
revivre ces expériences vivre pour la
dernière fois une rentrée scolaire
excitante vivre pour la dernière fois
les cours les activités et les
récréations vivre pour la dernière fois
un nouvel an où tout le monde est encore
là
vivre la cérémonie de remise des
diplômes et voir la fierté dans les yeux
de nos parents et leurs et le bonheur
qui remplit leur coeur vivre tous ces
moments merveilleux où on savait ce qui
allait se passer
mais je me suis rendu compte que la vie
est pleine de surprises et je n'allais
pas vivre ces choses comme les plus âgés
les problèmes ont commencé à s'enchaîner
dès le début du mois de septembre et on
a on arrive à une date emblématique
désormais dans l'histoire contemporaine
libanaise la révolution du 17 octobre
à cause de plusieurs problèmes le peuple
libanais s'est rassemblée pour se
manifester pour exprimer leur
frustration et leur colère le
gouvernement a démissionné quelques
heures après la livre libanaise a perdu
beaucoup de sa valeur une anarchie
totale s'est instauré sur tout le pays
bref un gros bordel
les problèmes ont continué à s'enchaîner
jusqu'à arriver au mois de mars
qui dit mois de mars dit début de la
crise du conte vide comme vous et comme
tout le monde on a vécu une période de
confinement horrible on était tout seul
on était loin du monde et c'est comme si
la vie réelle était arrêté mais en plus
de ça et en plus de tout autre chose
horrible que je n'ai pas mentionné le
peuple libanais passer par une des pires
crises de sa vie et à un certain point
je suis arrivé au summum de ma
frustration je n'en pouvais plus la
tristesse a pris le dessus sur ma vie
mais je doutais de beaucoup de choses
mais j'étais sûr d'une seule et c'est
que rien est constant j'ai compris la
phrase que la seule constante dans la
vie c'est le changement et du coup je
peux changer ma situation et je peux en
sortir et c'est là que tombe la première
étape de la leçon de vie que j'ai
apprise reconsidérer j'ai commencé à
reconsidérer les éléments qui
constituent ma vie est comme ça j'ai pu
faire le tri entre les choses que je
peux changer et les choses que je ne
peux pas changer cela paraît assez
simple mais en faisant ça je me suis
permis de me concentrer sur mes
priorités et laisser de côté les choses
qui sont hors mes capacités
et je sais très bien que si je n'aurais
pas fait ça la période auraient été
beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile
le temps plus le temps passait et plus
la situation au liban s'empirer
la crise devenait de plus en plus
désastreuse
est arrivé à l'explosion du port de
beyrouth j'ai atteint le deuxième summum
de frustration
le 5 août 2020 je suis parti à beyrouth
comme je vous ai dit pour aider les
blessés
mais il écrit d'angoise et les images
que j'ai vues reste jusqu'à présent
coller dans ma tête
quand j'ai entendu la mère l'aurait une
mère pleurait parce qu'elle a perdu en
le même jour son mari et son fils
une nouvelle sensation d'angoissé
si créé en moi une angoisse jamais
ressenti auparavant
est très très lourde
j'étais rempli de ses sentiments et de
ceux ressentis sombre et triste je suis
rentré chez moi et j'ai essayé
d'intérioriser ce qui vient de se passer
et j'essaye jusqu'à présent de le faire
mais j'ai compris quelque chose j'ai
compris que je faisais face à un nouveau
problème très grave
et c'est là qu'intervient la deuxième
étape
de la leçon de vie que j'ai imprimé qui
est relativisée relativiser signifie
faire perdre le caractère absolu de
quelque chose en l'associant à quelque
chose d'autre
et quand j'ai lu cette définition j'ai
commencé à penser comment je peux
appliquer ça à ma vie
je me suis dit qu'au lieu de restreindre
l'explosion du port de beyrouth à des
émotions triste et des ressentis sombre
je me suis dit pourquoi ne pas utiliser
ses émotions pour me motiver et en faire
quelque chose de bien j'ai regardé
autour de moi j'ai vu des gens qui
étaient affectés par ce par cette
explosion et j'ai reconsidéré ma vie je
me suis considérer chanceux d'être
encore en vie de ne pas être affectée
autant que ses autres personnes ça
paraît aussi très très simple mais c'est
quand on regarde les choses de ce point
de vue on commence à apprécier ce qu'on
a et apprécier notre situation actuelle
et c'est quelque chose qu'on ne fait pas
assez souvent on prend notre vie comme
garantie et on ne sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver
l'explosion du port de beyrouth m'a
beaucoup touché mais l'année 2020 m'a
appris beaucoup de choses ça en fait le
cumul des expériences le cumul des
problèmes qui m'a appris cette leçon de
vie je viens de vous présenter les deux
premiers points qui sont reconsidéré et
relativiser
le dernier point s'intitule optimisé
optimisé est en fait le résultat des
deux premiers points car en fait quand
on reconsidère les éléments qui
constituent notre vie pour identifier
lesquels sont en priorité et lesquelles
ne sont pas pour après relativiser et
associés à chaque élément la valeur qui
lui correspond on arrive à optimiser
optimisé signifie donner les meilleures
conditions de performance à quelque
chose et en effet quand on suit cet
acheminement c'est ce que je me suis
rendu compte quand on suit les deux
étapes de reconsidérer et relativiser on
arrive à un point on se met dans les
meilleures conditions pour prendre des
décisions qui nous reflète et qui nous
conviennent
c'est pour ça je vous dis n'ayez pas
peur des difficultés n'ayez pas peur de
l'adversité
car c'est uniquement quand on touche le
fond qu'on arrive à voir le sommet et
qu'on est déterminé pour l'atteindre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]